♪♪
-♪ Today started
just like any other day ♪
♪ I woke up to my alarm
at half past 8:00 ♪
-♪ I drank a cup of
coffee, read the paper,
ate a scone ♪
♪ Then I turned
my attention to my phone ♪
♪ And something happened
that I cannot undo ♪
♪ Something so devastating,
I must tellin' that a-you ♪
♪ I liked an Instagram post ♪
♪ From 2012 ♪
♪ On somebody's page ♪
♪ That I don't know super-well ♪
♪ I can't believe what I did ♪
♪ There's no coming back
from this ♪
♪ I'm selling all of my stuff ♪
♪ And moving to France ♪
-♪ I just bought a wig ♪
♪ And some shades ♪
-♪ I packed a bag ♪
♪ And brought cash for 80 days ♪
♪ I'm getting a fake passport ♪
♪ That says I'm from Duluth ♪
♪ Gonna get on a plane ♪
♪ Now my name is Craig ♪
-♪ Now my name is Craig ♪
-♪ I'm going to kill everyone
who knows what I did ♪
-♪ I'm gonna bury the bodies
in a public park ♪
-♪ I'm gonna work on a dock in
the South of France ♪
-♪ I'm gonna be on
the run till I die ♪
-♪ Be on the run till I die ♪
♪ I liked an Instagram post ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]